hey what's up guy isn't kabhi HD here
and this is LG V 30 this is way better
than any other phone LG's ever made and
it is so very 2017 so LG was nice enough
to send over a V 30 a little bit early
for me to take a look at it so I've
spent a little time with it and it's
kind of funny it's basically the
opposite of the essential phone I just
reviewed like in every imaginable way
it's kind of impressive one is a minimal
sort of bare-bones
small stock phone from a pretty new
company while the other is a big feature
packed really richly enhanced Android
flagship from a well-established company
has done this before now technically
they don't want us reviewing it yet
since this is pre-release hardware and
software but I really want to share it
with you guys because it's so good so
these are the top 5 things that you
should know about this phone in order so
number 5 is all the little things all
the attention to detail in this phone
and I think a lot of us can come from
the fact that LG has had a lot to learn
from the v20 and the g6 and the g5 but
some of it is just knowing what people
want and this phone checks pretty much
all of the boxes imaginable it has
expandable storage via microSD for those
who like it
it has wireless charging it has fast
charging it has USB type-c of course it
has IP certified waterproofing it has a
headphone jack and not only does it have
a headphone jack but it backs it up with
a 32-bit quad DAC
that audio enthusiasts will really like
the removable battery might be gone but
the 3300 milliamp hour battery onboard
here is pretty promising if not standard
for this sized it's not something I've
tested but fast charging and wireless
charging should back that up so again it
seems like the opposite of that
essential phone which for 700 bucks had
literally none of the things that I just
mentioned it gets the fingerprint reader
right also it puts it in the middle of
the back if you're gonna put it on the
back of the phone that's where it's
actually reachable Samsung and it also
doubles as a power button still which is
kind of LG's thing so the v3 checks all
the boxes in a way that no other
smartphone this year really has except
for maybe the thousand dollar note 8 so
number four is the software and I've
said this a couple times in previous
videos but I'm not the biggest Android
skin
so it takes a lot for me to say this
about a phone but I really don't mind
this skin and I think a big part of that
for me is how many features elegies
added again think the opposite of the
essential phone this is an LG skin on
top of Android 7.1.2 fingers crossed for
a getting updated to 8.0 quickly and
right off the bat it doesn't feel too
cartoonish or weird there is a bit of
bloatware but most of it you can remove
or hide if you want and performance is
not only smooth as you would expect but
like really fluid high frame rate
animations you can't say that about
every new phone with the skin but yeah
it just berries so many features in the
settings to mess with if you want you
know previous V Sirius phones the v10
the V 20 had that second screen
obviously this one doesn't have that but
they do have this optional floating bar
so you can bring it in from the edge and
keep some app shortcuts there or your
favorite actions whatever you want it's
basically kind of like apps edge on the
new Samsung phones you can rearrange the
buttons in the bottom of the phone and
any order you want so you can add or
remove buttons place it exactly how you
want if you take a lot of screenshots
you can add that capture button there
I'm happy to see that still exists
there's all these smart settings to to
adjust profiles basically based on
different scenarios so linger at home it
might turn on Wi-Fi and Bluetooth and
turn down the brightness and set your
alarm but when you get to work it does
something different it has a couple
themes built in too and then of course a
themes store if none of the built-in
ones suit your fancy so if you're into
that you can really make this phone look
a lot different so there's a lot going
on here with the software obviously
because it's Android you can use as much
of it or as little of it as you want so
you might not be interested in any of
the things I just mentioned in which
case you never touch them but if you're
interested any of that it's all included
so the number three best feature of the
V 30 is the design so you've seen it a
lot by now in this video but yeah it's
pretty dope this is one of those phones
that now looks very 2017 it's the huge
display up front the 82% screen to body
ratio that kind of curves over at the
edges it makes this sort of a glass
sandwich design it's not anything we
haven't seen before in fact if you
didn't know better you might say it
looks a lot like a Galaxy Note 8 because
it does but yeah the sides sort of round
off smoothly you've got the antenna
bands matching pretty well a really thin
and lightweight device in the hand IP
certified water-resistant again like
design is really complete and this is
sort of what you'd expect when you put a
dream phone together minimal bezels the
camera bump on the back is the tiniest
of bumps so no big deal it doesn't Rock
the phone or anything when it's down and
the logos aren't too much of an eyesore
either they're really my only real
complaint with the design is I wish
they'd put the headphone jack on the
bottom that's it so everything else is
props LG so then we get to number two
and the number two best feature on this
phone is the display itself up front
this new screen is incredibly good it's
a six inch 2880 by 1440p OLED display
and it gets crazy bright so I don't have
an it's rating for it but it is totally
visible outdoors much more easily than
most and honestly rivals some of the
best Samsung displays we've seen in the
past year two in colors and brightness
and clarity and saturation
now obviously 2880 by 1440 that's an 18
by 9 aspect ratio or as I like to call
it since I learn fractions two to one so
it's a bit narrower than your typical
sixteen by nine so when you're watching
videos or using certain apps sometimes
gaming you'll get these black bars on
either side of the display but again
it's not that big of a deal since it's
an OLED and the black parts of the
screen go completely blank the viewing
angles are pretty good the curved
corners are really great I mean this is
all-around great display and I think
this is what would really put it on the
map for me if I hadn't seen this phone
in person and I was just kind of curious
about it and I saw this screen that's
why I would be interested in it and then
it would get me to the rest of stuff but
that's just the second best thing so to
top that the number one best feature on
the v30 is around the back and it's that
camera or those cameras this phone
supports dual cameras again like all its
older brothers on the back gets one 16
megapixel F 1.6 main camera with oh is
and then a secondary super wide angle 13
megapixel F 1.9 camera and they've done
these dual cameras before with the
wide-angle secondary this time just with
pretty much everything around them being
improved so the main cameras a lot
better shots off this thing looked
top-notch I gonna have to disclaim that
it's pre-production stuff but they're
clean they have punch saturated colors
plenty of contrast and detail and
dynamic range and of course having a
fixed F 1.6 aperture means you can get
pretty close to a subject and on the
background will fade away to a decent
bokeh which is cool and then the super
wide angle camera has less distortion
than before so less of that fisheye
GoPro look and more of just a really
wide angle rectilinear perspective which
is awesome and then the camera app
itself is really impressive really what
makes this the number one feature so you
can drag the shutter button to move
between the two cameras zoom in and out
which is smart that's also what Samsung
is doing with the note so it's not the
first place we've seen it but it's very
2017 and it has your usual massive
amount of settings auto HDR auto phone
triggers self timers all that stuff but
then you look at all the modes look at
all these modes in the phone auto mode
is obviously the one that most people
use but enthusiasts will get into manual
mode manual video time lapses panoramas
slow-motion all that stuff and then
there is something called cine mode and
when you turn on cine mode the camera
records to a flat log color profile so
you can maximize sensor data and dynamic
range and then add color later the cine
mode in this phone's video camera is
literally made for people to import it
from the phone and bring it to a
computer and edit it later if that's not
screaming enthusiasm to you I don't know
what is so this is kind of the ultimate
enthusiasts photo and video cameras
obviously stuff like the video quality
itself and more photo quality testing
and the battery life those things will
have to be tested for a full review but
right off the bat v30
looks really promising and I didn't even
cover everything but it's pretty clear
this will be a mobile photography and
videography powerhouse and a phone that
enthusiasts who like all those boxes to
be checked will really like so let me
know would you get a V 30 I mean
obviously with note 8 right around the
corner
with iPhone 8 about to come out possibly
having an excellent camera as well is be
fair deal on your radar let me know
thanks for watching talk to you as the
next one peace
[Music]